[Music]
now throughout my travels across asia
there's always one dish that i was
desperate to taste
spicy delicious meatballs packed with
the most amazing flavor so today i'm
going to show you how to make a
delicious thai style lettuce wrap right
oscar pan down pan down traditionally
we're making these with pork but today
i'm gonna do the lamb okay super lean
incredibly healthy so it's sort of
almost like a hodgepodge smorgasbord of
bits and bobs put together beautiful
chives coriander lettuce chinese lettuce
baby cucumbers radishes leftover rice a
little bit of chili which will get
really nice and crispy and then a nice
fragrant thai chili paste
now first off let's have 10 minutes on
the clock please
right
let's get the lamb in there like i said
traditionally it's done with pork and
beef but today's gonna be lamb so salt
and pepper
okay a touch of chili flake
yes
the thai paste which is a really nice
fragrant paste in and because it's lamb
okay it doesn't need a lot
of work okay it's mince i like to put a
little bit of olive oil in there and
then you just literally scrunch that up
now the seasoning salt
and pepper and then of course
lime
lamb needs that level of acidity it was
pork or lamb it's still needed so
lime zest in
okay and that makes it a little bit more
fragrant
but
packed with flavor
now from there give that a really good
mix okay
i don't like adding egg egg gives it a
sort of
strange texture you can't really
identify it's lamb
i like to go into sort of golf ball
sizes okay
roll
and once you've got the golf ball size
two fingers on and just pat round so
it's almost like a
a sort of fish cake
shape
almost like a little miniature hockey
puck okay beautifully done now too thick
and
an actual nightmare
to literally cook evenly so i like them
a sort of centimetre the nice thing
about these is they don't need to be
perfectly shaped just get your golf ball
round two fingers on top
pat it and then in between your index
finger and your thumb okay
and yeah one more two more round
on top
down round
two fingers on top and then lift it up
and shape it beautifully okay now clean
the hands
okay now we've got the shape pan
get it nice and hot get your second pan
nice and hot as well
and get that rice nice and crispy and so
this dish sort of comes together
uh beautifully because
it's almost done
with like leftovers
okay in
squash them down again as they go in get
some color on there push them down
again in
and push them down in
and push them down remember the actual
lamb is cold on top so
he's not gonna burn yourself pan for the
rice from there
get that rice in
and get it nice and flat again okay use
the back of the spoon
and sort of pat that down okay
pat pat pat and that's gonna get it
really nice and crispy
okay in that rice i'm gonna take a chili
and literally just slice it nice and
thinly okay
nice and thinly
seeds in
okay fresh chili
and sort of
caramelize beautiful crispy rice is
amazing
sit that on there
i'll take a little touch of coriander
cilantro
same thing different country up
and then literally in
i'm going to come back to that in a
minute let that sit there and get nice
and crispy
now for the nam jim sauce
first off
we start off with fish sauce
one nice tablespoon with about five
little dabs
one tablespoon
in
fish sauce gives that really nice sour
flavor and after that
a nice tablespoon of maple syrup
okay three glugs one big spoon
a touch of chili in there
some beautiful toasted peanuts in there
okay
now
look at the
look at the cakes
look at the meatballs turn them over for
that nice spicy smell gas goes
up a touch
roll them to the side
let that pan do the work tilt the pan
and it helps cook down the center of
that
let's get it nice and crispy
this dipping sauce is something you can
make up at the beginning of the week
and it just sits there
i like it on fish i like on chicken and
equally as delicious
especially with lamb
now fresh lime
roll that light
very heavily done
when you roll it like that it helps to
break down
all that juice so when you come to
squeeze it
it's absolutely packed
with flavor beautiful
now now i'm jim done
mix that up
into the bowl
beautifully done
really nice beautiful dipping sauce rice
give that a nice little toss look at the
color of that as you've got that nice
and crispy
back down and push it back down all i
want is the color on there chili's
working his magic
and look i'm gonna make that a touch
more fragrant time please
five minutes halfway
get your grater
zest over that rice it's gonna make a
really nice fragrant crispy rice so
tasty
really tasty
cilantro fresh chili
cilantro fresh chili
and lime zest
beautiful
now look at these
gas down
beauty done
now
we're going to start
sort of
building up this plate okay i've got my
big sort of lettuce leaves that's the
outside
lettuce leaves and that's going to be
like sort of cup
okay and the idea here is you sort of
almost like going into a pickle mix
you sort of take a little bit of the
radish
a little bit of the cucumber
the cucumber gives it the refreshness
cools down the heat
and
it's so tasty especially with the lamb
again the radish a nice mild onion
flavor so good
next there you've got these beautiful
large spring onions cut them
on the bias
right in the side you sort of
cool down those lettuce cups with the
amazing spring onions
look the radishes don't slice them just
cut them in half and then into quarters
and look
they can sit there
all day long the stalks are so tasty
don't throw them away
again in half
and then each half into quarter as you
can see this lovely little plethora of
ingredients so it's all coming together
beautifully
chives don't over chop them do nice
batons so you can taste the chives okay
big thick
batters of chives stick them
in the middle and then from there
your cilantro literally just through and
what i like to do is just chop it
roughly
and just sort of put a nice little mound
there
and now look you can see that plate
coming together
watch
because this land has no fat in there
these things cook so beautifully and so
quickly
all right give that a little turn
so crispy beautiful
time please
and then
you start
lifting this this plethora
of asian flavor
almost a little bit sort of street food
especially the lettuce cup and you start
literally
piling this up
used to be done
and then with the rice
look how crispy that is
all you do then is just drop that rice
on top
of
your beautiful
amazing
thai
style meatballs
i love eating rice like this
it's just so healthy light crispy
and so moorish
amazing
here goes on
there goes over there
and there you go there's your rice
crispy and steaming and there we have
our beautiful lamb
thai style meatballs a perfect platter
for a great feast
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsey
intent cookbook inspired by this series
and trust me you want to come out a much
better chef and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck
you